the carmaker's the food producers the
aircraft manufacturers jobs at risk if
the next prime minister really does
decide to activate a No Deal procs it
the business secretary clear a No Deal
must be avoided at all costs are people
going to lose their jobs in a no
delbruck set yes of course it's it's
evident that if you hadn't the
disruption that comes from a No Deal
wreckage there were people that'll be
people that that will lose their jobs
it's that thousands of jobs in a no deal
bracket it many thousands of jobs for
three years now businesses of all shapes
and sizes that have pointed out the
costs that were incurred my views are
very well known I think a No Deal breaks
it would be enormously damaging for our
country but brexit II colleagues not
much interested in his evidence No Deal
no problem he's an arch remainer he
voted remain he argued for a name he's
always argued for remain he's never
gonna change his mind once we've left I
believe I'll be right and he'll be wrong
on the morning of the first of November
the Sun will rise on a free country and
I intend to stay up like mark Francois
leaving the EU Deal or No Deal is a new
dawn for a free country but Greg Clark
and many many others believe that a No
Deal would be ruinous the British public
voted to leave the EU but did they
really want to leave with no deal even
at this late stage that's a question
that hasn't really been answered there
were protests in Parliament Square on
March the 29th when brexit Dave didn't
dawn the Conservative Party in the main
clear there will be no delay again but
if no delay means no deal there will be
a price will it be worth paying
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster